President Trump says he's willing to
take an oath when he talks to Special
Counsel Robert Muller the president told
White House reporters that his interview
for the Russia investigation is likely
to happen in two or three weeks if his
lawyers are okay with that Paula Reid is
at the Justice Department Paula good
morning what else do we know about the
format of this potential interview we
know it's still being worked out whether
this will be in person in writing or
some combination of the two
now when the president speaks with
investigators he's not actually under
oath he would only go under oath if he's
asked to testify before the grand jury
the other big question that a lot of
people have is will this be recorded the
president made a big deal about the fact
that secretary Clinton's interview with
the FBI was not recorded and while
there's nothing preventing a camera from
being in the room it's unlikely that his
lawyers will want that it's interesting
in my reporting on the president and his
other legal issues when you read
depositions that he's done he's the
consummate executive he's not the the
man that you sometimes see on Twitter or
in the campaign trail he answers the
questions he sticks to the script but
it's possible that if you introduce a
camera into the situation you might get
something different well what do we know
about what would happen to whatever the
transcript the audio recording or
whatever it happens to record this
moment will that be locked tight or will
the public ever get to see it it's
unlikely that his interview with
investigators would be made public
unless it was leaked if he is called to
testify before a grand jury it would be
up to the court whether or not to
release that testimony there's of course
that famous video of President Clinton
that is his grand jury testimony that
they worked out a deal where that would
be recorded so he didn't have to come to
court that's interesting I was reading
the law this morning and one of the
reasons that the judge can use to
release a video or a transcript of grand
jury testimony is if the subject of the
interview talks to the press lots of
information there apology thank you very
much